there's a reason Nicholas Cage is such a
memeable member of Hollywood he's pretty
hilarious often unintentionally so
sometimes it totally works for him I
said put the bunny back in the box in
the 2006 remake of the Wicker man though
the joke was only on him in the film he
played an ill-fated detective who's
generously treed out to Parts Unknown to
look for his ex- fiance's daughter what
he ends up encountering is a cult of
man- murdering witches who make it a
game to let him feel like he's just
heroically rescued the girl only to have
her return him right into their clutches
so they can sacrifice him to their
beaking mother spirit in the process of
his tortuous demise the sisters enclose
him in a mask of bees his flailing
screaming reaction is monumentally funny
given the gravity of the situation what
is that what is that what is it oh no
not the Beast not the
be the film now enjoys a cult notoriety
odow to Cage's perform performance which
here is an outright classic example of
overacting of all the people who have
portrayed Batman's most iconic Nemesis
Jared Leto was the weirdest and believed
by many to be the least successful The
Joker is at his simplest a manifestation
of chaos and the way Humanity would go
if people gave up on the idea of being
good to one another he's not someone
whose ultimate goal is personal wealth
or his sexual satisfaction yet that's
how Leto played him a garish smarmy
Lobster who spent a little too much time
curating his Instagram feed in The
Suicide Squad scene where he and Margot
Robbie's Harley Quinn are standing over
multiple Vats of acid at ace chemicals
Leto's Joker is over mannered and creepy
enough to make a viewer skin crawl but
not in the brilliantly unsettling way
Heath Ledger Did in the Dark Knight
anyone watching him in the scene might
very well feel the need to jump into the
screen to keep Robbie from being exposed
to such a weird repulsive speech about
living and dying would you die for me
yeah yes the Joker is supposed to be
scary and uncanny but in regards to
Harley Quinn he also needs to be
believably charismatic Leto utterly
fails in this regard Bonnie Wright and
Daniel Radcliffe have little to no
chemistry through much of the Harry
Potter film series despite the fact that
Jenny and Harry have a sweet banter fill
development as a couple in the books
it's not a central focus of the story
it's not a central focus of the story in
the movies either but their relationship
still serves an important purpose and
it's one simple not supported by what is
seen on screen for example what happens
in Harry Potter and the halfblood prince
in this scene jinny helps Harry dispose
of the halfblood princes potions
textbook in the room of requirement it's
a scene made exclusively for the movie
and it's painfully obvious the writers
were trying to wrap up a loose end while
developing Jenny and Harry's
relationship in the same scene
unfortunately it's one of only two
scenes where Jenny and Harry are alone
in the entirety of the film and their
chemistry is not sufficient enough to be
conveyed in just a few scenes Wright was
cast as Jenny when she was just a little
kid so few could have predicted that she
wouldn't be up to task of carrying a key
element of Harry's eventual story she
recites her lines like a high schooler
reading aloud in English class frankly
and it's really difficult to understand
why Harry would be interested in her at
all that can stay hidden up here too if
you
like the 50 Shades of Gray Trilogy never
needed to be a peak artistic screen
adaptation of its source material this
makes sense because the source material
is essentially just alternate univers
Twilight fanfiction that misrepresents
the nature of sexual BDSM relationships
arguably the only thing the movie did
need to do was provide the ver with
steamy love scenes where the chemistry
between its two romantic leads sparked
like a live wire unfortunately as in
this scene 50 Shades of Gray the movie
failed to deliver on that front Dakota
Johnson and Jamie Dornan who were
rumored to dislike each other throughout
the filming of the trilogy though
Johnson is sense debunk those rumors had
absolutely no sexual chemistry in all of
the scenes of what should be two people
realizing their sexual compatibility
Everything feels awkward and forced at
one point doran's Christian lays
Johnson's Anastasia face down on a table
and it looks like an SNL spoof of a sex
scene thanks to the actor's awkward
footwork and relatively blank
Expressions they're uncomfortable to
watch together and neither of them is a
good enough actor to make up for their
lack of chemistry Johnson doesn't know
who her character is supposed to be and
it shows while doran's American accent
is far more off-putting than sexily
commanding there are a lot of bad acting
and memeable moments in the Harry Potter
films but one of the most fan
scrutinized takes place in the fourth
movie Harry Potter and the Goblet of
Fire in the film The Magical Goblet of
Fire spits out Harry's name for
participation in a brutal student
contest known as the tri wizard
tournament Dumbledore needs to make sure
Harry isn't responsible for this turn of
events you put your name c the fire it's
alarming aggressive and completely at
odds with how the scene is described
described in chapter 17 of the book upon
which the movie was based in which JK
Rowling wrote that Dumbledore asked
calmly if Harry put his own name in The
Goblin this over-the-top scene very well
could be a case of bad acting notes from
director Mike Newell but In fairness he
may have been distracted by his cracked
ribs at the time given that Michael
gamon's performances as Dumbledore are
otherwise consistent across all the
movies in which he appeared having
replace Richard Harris who died after
filming Harry Potter in the Chamber of
Secrets and several different directors
it's an liar where did it begin with
cats every scene is so badly acted badly
motion captured and badly conceived on
every imaginable level that it seems
unlikely anyone who's ever seen it will
ever forget it the 2019 adaptation of
Sir Andrew Lloyd Weber's long-running
musical somehow managed to drag in stars
as venerable as Judy Dench Ian McKellen
Taylor Swift and Jennifer Hudson to
prance around in digital fur few of them
get away with their dignity intact and
few of them have more to lose than Idris
Elba the British star defined gangster
cool for a generation as Stringer Bell
on The Wire landed scen stealing rolls
in Blockbuster franchises from Thor to
Suicide Squad to Fast and Furious to
Star Trek and became The Internet's
number one choice for the next James
Bond we can only imagine those online
petitions lost a whole lot of signatures
after Elba appeared as mcavity the
magically powered villain of the piece
elba's signature stoic cool has deserted
him all through the movie not helped At
All by an unsettling character design
that leaves him frequent bare naked in
flesh colored fur he sounds less like
the stoic tough guys Elba made his name
playing or the menacing Master criminal
he's supposed to be and more like a
chipper birthday clown okay yes the
January Jones character in X-Men first
Class is named Emma Frost she's not
supposed to be a particularly warm and
emotive person but she's also not
supposed to speak in a monotone voice
with all the energy of a seventh grade
substitute teacher January Jones once
did great work on Mad Men as Betty
Draper but Betty's complete repression
of of personality and desire shouldn't
be applied to a character like Emma
Frost she's meant to be sharp insexual
occasionally bored sure but never vacant
in this particular scene Frost is
confronted by Magneto and Professor X
about Sebastian Shaw's whereabouts they
might as well be asking her for
directions to the nearest bathroom if
there's anything that would get Emma
Frost excited it's a confrontation with
two of the most powerful mutants she
should be angling for every second of
this interaction but instead Jones
relies on her physical Beauty to do all
the heavy lifting she might look the
part but her performance doesn't do
justice to the popular comic book
character you can stop trying to read my
mind sugar 2016 Super anti-hero flick
Suicide Squad was popular enough to rate
a sequel of sorts with the suicide squad
but word of mouth was so overwhelmingly
negative that as the name implies James
gun sequel was as much a fresh start as
a follow-up and if you want to know why
look no further than the introduction of
katana the token superhero in this moely
crew of super villains a big part of
this movie's notorious reputation is the
uneven pacing the plot can't even get
started until it's already half over
since the first half gets eaten up with
extended introductions for each
character in the large cast well most of
them poor Katana ends up having the same
amount of information crammed into a
couple of seconds and Joel kinaman as
squad leader Rick flag rattles it off
like he's got 10 minutes left before tea
time this is Katana she's got my back
she cut all you in half with one sword
stroke just like Mo the lawn or with his
stop start delivery maybe it sounds more
like he's making it up as he goes along
slowing down as if he's thinking of what
to say next then suddenly speeding
through the rest of the
delivery this is not the first time Jack
and Jill has been included on a list of
movies that failed and it likely won't
be the last even before the movie came
out people were skeptical that the Adam
Sandler vehicle in which he played both
Jack and dressed in drag to play Jack ex
twin sister Jill would be worth watching
and his since earned distinction is
perhaps the worst of Sandler's worst
movies the entire thing is a train wreck
but the Thanksgiving dinner scene is a
good Showcase of how poly Sandler
handles both of the film's titular roles
it's not unreasonable that Jack is
disgusted by Jill when it is revealed
that she's been touching him somewhat
inappropriately or trying to for a lot
of their lives but Sandler plays the
discuss not like someone with a
complicated and traumatic relationship
with the sibling but rather like a man
repuls by the vision of himself in a wig
in fake boobs as Jill Sandler is
ridiculous There is almost nothing
feminine about his portrayal to the
point where it's no longer a cheap joke
about an ugly woman but rather just
terrible acting the movie is horribly
written but Sandler's performance is one
of its worst elements Mickey Rooney's
role in the 1961 Audrey heurn classic
Breakfast at Tiffany's is frequently
cited as one of Hollywood's most
upsetting racist screen depictions and
that's really saying something Rooney
plays Mr yunioshi Holly goly's grumpy
grading landlord who is perpetually put
out by his tenants careless attitude the
most shocking thing about the role by
far is that it is a racist condescending
example of yellowface a term used to
refer to ethnically Asian onscreen
characters being played by white actors
Rooney's portrayal is an unfunny
caricature of a caricature and the fact
that it's a bad performance seems like
the least of its faults watching Rooney
stumble around his apartment throughout
the beginning of the scene is cringe
inducing his clumsiness is laughably
unconvincing and his frustration with
Holly for buzzing him after once again
for getting her key to get in the
building is over the top and feels like
a scene from a stage musical today
Tiffany is held up as a classic
nonetheless Rooney's performance is a
stain on both the film and Rooney's
lengthy career mital
r one of the true Classics of modern so
bad its goodness bmic Shak and Terror
built most of its cult on the back of
it's hilariously unconvincing killer
birds and they're quite the sight
embarrassingly lowquality computer
Creations hanging in space as their wing
tips wiggle and they squawk monotonously
but there's no shortage of bad human
acting here despite the imminent threat
of bird murder the stars of bmic don't
do much but take a leisurely drive down
the California coast giving them the
opportunity to meet a whole menagerie of
awful performances we've got to give the
gold to Steven gustavson as a forest
dwelling hermit and a legendary bad wig
who rants about dark beetles and other
environmental bugaboos but the episodic
plot has to keep moving and you can hear
the gears grinding as writer director
James wi hastily writes The Hermit out
of the
script I hear a mountain line I got to
get back to my house you better get to
your car it was very nice meeting you
that's ridiculous enough but it's
gustafson's performance that sells it
with his wobbly voice and a tone that
sounds like he's just about fed up with
these obnoxious guests and wants to make
up any excuse to shoe them out of his
Woods there's no shortage of bad
performances in Lost in Space there's
the Staggering miscalculation of casting
friend star Matt LeBlanc as a badass
Space Marine there's future Mean Girl
star Lacy shabar putting on an
earpiercing high nasal voice that's
somehow more cartoony than her role as
an actual cartoon character in The Wild
Thornberries and then there's William
Hurt who cannot sound less invested for
an emotionally charged scene that calls
for him to say goodbye to his wife
before leaving to explore an Uncharted
Planet possibly never to return he
sounds more robotic than the actual
robot who plays a major role it doesn't
help any that he doesn't even call her
by name adding to the impression that he
really is a robot reading out lines of
code I love you wife that perfect storm
of bad writing and bad acting has caught
the public imagination enough to
resurface on the internet from time to
time but it's worth watching Lost in
Space all the way through to confirm
that yes her's whole performance is like
that it was pretty surprising when
variety announced that Ashton Kutcher
would be stepping into to play Steve
Jobs in an independently produced biopic
centering on the tech Titan who had
passed away the year prior in 2011 up
until that point Kutcher was best known
for comedic work on shows like that 70
show INF fronting the celebrity prank
show punked his bonafides weren't
exactly the kind usually associated with
a Prestige biopic about a troubled real
life figure but it wouldn't be the first
time a left field casting Choice worked
out unfortunately Kutcher's performance
and jobs wasn't good enough to
compensate for a script with terrible
pacing and a proclivity towards juvenile
comedy watching ccher try to play Jobs's
uncharming volatility in a scene where
he gets into a fight over his vision is
like watching a Harlem Globe Trotter
attempt to jockey in the Kentucky Derby
throughout the scene ker seems like he's
mere seconds away from breaking into
laughter there are other parts of the
movie where he plays jobs with more
effective Nuance but this scene almost
feels like an SNL impression I already
fired you his dramatic performance in a
more recent movie Vengeance was much
better because it left him room to lean
into his own brain of Charisma one in
complete opposition to that of the real
Steve Jobs Kutcher's Charisma is
inherent and Whimsical while jobs was
notoriously begrudging and
intimidating financially speaking there
is perhaps no actor whose career got off
to a better start than Orlando Bloom
between 2001 and 2005 he released three
Lord of the Rings films the same number
of Pirates of the Caribbean films and
also appeared in the Blockbuster
Blackhawk Down all grossing well over
100 million dollar domestically all
making a cultural impact Bloom then made
the seemingly no-brainer decision to
work with say anything Jerry Maguire
Almost Famous Maestro Cameron Crow on a
dramedy called Elizabeth Town everything
went downhill from there his performance
in the movie isn't all bad but in this
particular scene with Kiren Dunst he
sounds like someone who just recently
learned English attempting to play a
native English speaker this is
particularly sad because he is a native
English speaker he just has a British
accent instead of a generic West Coast
American one it's like he doesn't know
how to use contractions or stress the
correct syllables in many of the words
he's using and it's easy to imagine that
dunce's confused look is more because of
that than Bloom's character being so
Charming what I am saying is good before
Timothy shalamay and Deni VNV decided to
resurrect Dune sci-fi author Frank
Herbert's magnum opus there was the
David Lynch dud that came out in 1984
and co-star Sting the singer from the
band The Police unsurprisingly sting
didn't do too much more acting following
his role as fade rotha hekinan most
likely because it's pretty difficult to
take him seriously as a dangerous threat
to Paul or any other characters in the
film fade is supposed to be an
extraordinary Warrior perhaps the
greatest alive as well as Cutthroat and
particularly obsessed with the
eviscerating paulit trates sting goes
very over the top in the scene leading
up to his character's death where in
fade and Paul duel over the fate of
oracus I will kill
him
fade is supposed to provide a
destructively expressive Counterpoint to
Paul's composure and resignation in the
scene not supposed to be funny there are
times when sting himself seems to be
unable to keep the corners of his mouth
from turning up as he throws a tantrum
and tantrum is the word for it despite
the fact that fade is supposed to be
intensely terrifying there should be
some suspense as to whether Paul is
going to win the duel and because that
can't come from the plot since the
central protagonist in a saga like Dune
doesn't usually die in a night fight it
has to come from a believably vicious
fade Jean Wilder's Willy Wonka in the
1971 classic Willy Wonka in the
Chocolate Factory became iconic Johnny
Depp didn't stand much of a chance in
succeeding with his take on the same
character in Charlie in the Chocolate
Factory regardless of the actual quality
of his performance but he made a lot of
very strange acting choices panned by
critics and audiences alike it's
possible he was trying to distinguish
himself from Wilder but there must be
ways to do that outside of seeing how
much you can disturb an audience before
people start walking out in this scene
Wonka is bringing his golden ticket
contest winners into the factory and
becomes immediately wildly uneasy by the
presence of multiple children reminder
Wonka is a chocolate maker yes he's
supposed to be somewhat unfeeling
towards the kids but he's not supposed
to forget how to function in front of
them
oh I don't care Deb plays Wonka like
someone who has lived their entire life
in silence in a cardboard box and only
emerged the prior Tuesday a fair amount
of this is informed by Tim Burton's
bizar rri but Depp's acting doesn't help
Cameron Diaz was miscast in Gangs of New
York for one thing she simply does not
look like a young Irish immigrant from a
Civil War era New York City between her
tan complexion and her unconvincing
red-haired wig she has a looked fit for
modern movies more to the point the
biggest reason Diaz was Miss gast's
Jenny is because she just couldn't do
the part Justice in such a dramatic
Prestige picture in this scene opposite
Leonardo DiCaprio Diaz isn't able to
convey Jenny's ferocity as a poor young
woman attempting to make her way in a
world stacked against her DiCaprio and
Diaz don't have very much onscreen
chemistry and their characters suffer
for it Diaz fails to make Jenny
convincing as a worthy adversary for
DiCaprio's Amsterdam she fails to convey
anything other than the Rope
half-heartedly antagonistic sass of a
romantic lead in a romcom about Rivals
who become
lovers I don't know which one's yours
Silent Night deadly night part two is
only barely a movie about half of it is
just recycled from the original deadly
Knight as narrated by a character who
didn't actually witness any of it so how
did it become such an evergreen cult
classic two words Eric Freeman Freeman's
performance is Ricky the younger brother
of the original Santa Claus costume
killer is exquisitly awful even the
Recycled footage is worth sitting
through just to hear him narrate over
sinking his teeth into every word and
dropping a sarcastic sneer in random
places and that's before he goes on on a
rampage of his own cackling in his own
apparently self-reloading gun the
writers weren't up to the task of coming
up with the snappy quip slasher fans
demand and when Ricky takes aim at some
poor slub taking his trash out they
can't think of anything better for him
to say garbage day fortunately Freeman
makes the most of it eye popping and
eyebrow waggling his way to online meme
dump it doesn't help that every other
aspect of this scene is just this
hysterically terrible with the editor
cutting the scene to shred so we get an
almost subliminal shot of the bullet
going through the victim's back and then
disappearing when we cut to a different
[Music]
angle